the original jackass the way it got on
mtv tell me if i'm wrong you and the
guys went out and did all your stuff and
then you sold it to mtv so in other
words the stuff had already been done
mtv wouldn't they knew you didn't die
right right we submitted some footage
from the skateboard videos we had done
that's right there was one point
i heard on the original tapes you gave
to mtv they wouldn't air this
you wanted somebody to shoot you with a
bullet while you wore a bulletproof vest
am i correct okay you couldn't find
anyone to shoot you you understand why
well i had my friend doing it but we got
out to the place to to do it and he said
i'm not doing it and the photographer
refused to take pictures and i was like
oh boy but you understand oh boy look at
these wimps but you understand why if
you die
they've essentially shot you and they're
going to end up in jail
right i understand why they didn't want
to but that you know i i just shot
myself right so that's the point of the
story so rather than give up on this
crazy notion you put on a bulletproof
vest
and you took the gun and shot yourself
in the chest
yeah
that's pretty close i mean you don't
know for real that it's going to work
people have died from that when the the
gun is too close
well and plus i didn't have a lot of
money at the time so i could only afford
the cheapest bulletproof vests they made
right and i called the place i'm like
you are your vests really good there's
our vests are great they're the best in
their business well okay well this is
what i'm going to do let us call you
back
and then they called back said we can't
recommend you do that and i was like ah
crap i already said i would was the most
dangerous thing you do in jackass 3d
when you uh almost broke your neck is
that is that the
is that the stunt so to speak with a
goal he was on a bull i tried to roller
skate in a buffalo herd too what is that
it's a roger miller song that i tried to
bring to life you tried to roller skate
into a buffalo her yeah all right and
what happened there well roger miller
was absolutely correct you cannot roller
skate in a buffalo hurt they knocked the
cow walking [ __ ] out of me
buffalo hit into you there was i there
was uh three are they stampeding at that
point yes and they hit you full on yes
and your body's thrown around like a rag
doll that's where you almost broke it
and that was right after i did the
invisible man so i almost break my neck
and then i'm like i go dust myself off
change clothes and then get run over by
some buffalo how many how many days in
between the stunts
no there was uh maybe an hour and a half
between the stunts hour and a half yeah
what's the invisible man that's when i
paint myself into a background yeah but
in the middle of a bullring
and the bull attacks you i got flipped
up in the air right before i hit the
ground the bull kicked me in the head
and it altered my course just enough
where it honestly helped me no fear when
you go and do that
yeah there's fear
what what is the rush because you're
getting in on film and you're going man
millions of people are going to laugh at
this and i and i feel good about it uh
but the right i just after you shoot it
and then me and my friend sit around and
look at the footage and laugh but
there's no real way of knowing if you'll
get killed or not i mean there's no real
way the first time you do it no there's
no no you don't know what's going to
happen really you know the bull is going
to try and smoke you but you don't know
but the stunt isn't successful unless
you get hit when you're roller skating
and right bulls are stampeding right and
they hit you that's the humor
and you know you're going to have to get
hit if it's going to be funny and
successful and in fact if you get really
thrown it's going to be funny and if
anything short of dying will be funny
yeah dying gets a little dark but uh you
know which of the three takes do you do
i mean what's that retakes of these they
don't work yeah there's retakes like i
did a thing where i tried to catch a
pass over the middle
uh and i'd had jared allen of the
minnesota vikings hit me yeah while i
was you know jumping up to catch the
ball and we shot that three times and he
hits hard he's like six six and he was
smoking me every time but it wasn't i
could tell it wasn't
what
i wanted or we wanted and be like okay
let's do it again is there any technique
involved in this so that you don't get
hurt or is it just like i'll just throw
myself up there and see what happens
well you gotta you gotta commit and you
gotta go in with the good uh point of
view if you get like real negative and
you half commit and then that's when
you're really going to get
that you don't get hurt you're going to
get injured i'm so shocked by you i
can't even i mean if i got a bruised rib
i'd be miserable bruised ribs suck by
the way yeah yeah they don't they're no
fun and i'm sure you got a bruised rib
when you get hit by a bunch of bulls or
a guy tackles you midair i mean come on
he kind of blew out my sternum right
here it was sticking up
he's sticking up doesn't concern you
that's dangerous do you go to a doctor
for that or you just say [ __ ] it just
put it back
you don't go to it not not that what i
do when you sternum is sticking through
your skin i mean it wasn't sticking
through my skin it was just kind of
popped up yeah popped out so what do you
do you laugh and then you just push on
it i didn't even tell you i told
uh
one friend about i didn't tell anybody
about it why i don't know i just you
don't like to complain
uh i just didn't see any reason to like
if it was if it was really bad i'd go to
the doctor if a guy complains is he a
[ __ ] no not at all is there a doctor on
the set oh we have ambulances
and medics and
is is this the end of the jackass
franchise now i mean are you done now
after jackass 3d are you going to hang
it up i mean you've gotten away with
this for 39 years all this crazy stunt
behavior is that it are you done well we
said we were done after one and after
two and here we're doing the third one
we're not going to make any predictions
anymore right we're the wrong people to
ask